okay guys so first off I just want to
say happy new year to all of you keep it
in mind that you live only once
life is short rules are meant to be
broken and having fun and creating
memories is all that truly matters today
I'm going to talk about faithful to
betraying northern houses about a fatal
to northern noble houses that fold for
MC Bolton against John snow and his
forces in the Battle of the bastards
John's forces which contain mostly free
folk aka the wildlings along with the
other minor note houses loyal to a how
stark which were housed moment house
hornwood house Mazen and as a savior of
the day house Aaron those two houses the
betrayed House Stark and fought for
house Bolton in the Battle of the
bastards our house Karstark and house
amber now when John is proclaimed as the
king in north there are important
decisions that John has to make
important decision about fate of those
two betraying houses also we need to
consider the fact that the North has
never been vehicles now at the noble
houses of the north are extinguished a
lot of other houses are weak while the
new owners the wildlings are also almost
extinguished John's decision won't be
easy to make a tall house Karstark in
house amber are one of the oldest noble
houses in the north but John still has
to punish them greatly since they try to
destroy House Stark
while house amber is also guilty for
recons death let's start with fate of
house Karstark after the battle the
bastards house Karstark is possibly
extinct vassal house that held filty to
how stark of Winterfell until the
execution of Lord Rickard Karstark it's
also interesting fact that House Stark
and House Karstark
have the same blood since Karen Stark
whose younger son of the king in north
was awarded with lands of the eastern
region of the north after putting down a
rebellion of house Bolton
which happened about a thousand years
ago over the time Carole's seat known as
Karl's whole became known as car hold
and the car whole Starks became known as
car starts in the first season when Robb
called his banners to march south rescue
his father Eddard Stark house Karstark
was loyal to House Stark and was among
Rob's army also in the first season
carrion Karstark
lisanna Rickard Karstark died in the
beginning of the war in one of the first
battles during the second season and
during Rob's campaign in the
westerland's Rob to acquit him an army
of 6,000 cavalry on which half of this
army was made up by Karstark soldiers
during the second season second son of
Lord Rickard Karstark torn Karstark was
killed by Sir Jaime Lannister during an
escape attempt later
Jaime was recaptured and nearly killed
by several car stock soldiers frustrated
by Torrance death after arguing with
Lord Rickard Karstark Catelyn Stark
released Jaime and order Brienne of
Tarth to deliver him safely to King's
Landing in hope that in return Jaime
will release her daughters in the third
season as an act of revenge against
House Lannister Lord Rickard Karstark
Lord of karhold braked into dungeons of
Riverrun and murdered Martin and Willem
Lannister which led Rob to execute Lord
Karstark under the charges of treason
which in my opinion was stupid active
Rob stupid Act which resulted with rob
lowes great size of the northern army
which resulted with Rob losing war and
also because of this the Karstarks along
with the Bolton's had their armies
intact following the red wedding Patrol
these events
Herald Karstark the youngest son Rickard
Karstark and younger brother of Harry on
and tauren Karstark became the new head
of House Karstark Carroll declared his
support to house Bolton the new Great
House of the north as the result of Robb
executing his father later her lands
were to Rose's call for help after Sansa
Starks escaped from Winterfell against
the eventual Lannister retribution
Herald Karstark also pledged allegiance
to Roos his son Ramsay Bolton at Ramsay
kill his father
along with stepmother and step brother
and took over the control over the north
Harold Karstark participated in the
battle against the forces of Jon Snow
furthermore Carroll led the cavalry
charge when John was standing all by
himself in the middle of the battlefield
Harald with his cavalry was seemingly
wiped out during the initial clash with
the stark Eberly ironically dealing
large part of Ramsay ordering his own
archers to fire on them
however HBO's viewer guide doesn't list
Harold Karstark as deceased which could
mean the Harold survived the battle even
if Harold Karstark survived he's going
to be executed for his treason there is
no doubt about it
but a born decision that journal had to
make is what to do with house car starts
lands and titles it's most likely the
lands castle and titles of house
Karstark will be divided between Starks
loyal houses maybe the history is going
to repeat maybe John will settlement as
Lord of karhold to command with former
Karstarks lands with his wildlings just
like thousand years ago when Carlin was
awarded with those same lands after he
also put it down Bolton's rebellion now
let's focus on fate of how somber just
like house Karstark how summer also rely
behind how stark in the world of five
kings with region number behind the
first to suggest crowning Robb Stark as
a king in the north
NL before him while after the red
wedding it was unknown what happened to
him since he was not attending during
the red wedding in season six smell G
number the eldest son of John number
became the head of house amber after his
father died and refused to pledge fealty
to house Bolton
but as cramsey Bolton to join forces
with him to fight a free fall that had
been led into the realm by John Snow the
main reason of smell gin asking Ramsay
to help him fight wildlings is because
of the fact that the seat of his house
which is the last heart is far north
close to the wall which gets smells in
fear of wildlings invasion smell G
number dislike house Bolton
but eventually sided ramsay to dry out
the thousands of wildlings that Jon Snow
allowed to pass through the wall to seal
the alliance between house amber and
house Bolton merging hands over Rickon
stark and OSHA to Ramsay while he also
presented the head of recon star wolf
shaggy-dog as a proof of boy's identity
if you don't remember bran stark sent
his brother Rican OSHA and shaggy-dog to
seek shelter at last heart the seat of
house amber because he told the amber so
loyal bannermen of the Starks at first
Ramsay questions merchants motives since
the Amber's were famous a loyal to House
Stark but smudging calendar house
Karstark has stark blood but still
Harold car star
became new Ramsay's lieutenant smell
gene also revealed Ramsey that Jon Snow
has led the Wilding army south of the
wall which was bad news for the umbers
since their Castle is further north than
any other Castle while the umbers were
forced to fight wildlings first
something that smell Jean once enjoyed
by this time it was different
there were too many wildlings and in his
opinion smudging had to request Ramsay's
help which led him to swear fealty to
Ramsay in the battle bastards smell
jameelah had the Bolton spear man who
formed a wall around stark army after
the stark army was surrounded by the
spearmen as we all know smudging climb
the wall bodies to fight in a circle
beginning with slaying and injured
wildling who was attempting to escape he
fought his way to Jon Snow but was swept
away by the crowd before they could
fight smell Jin then came face to face
with torment at almost killin but was
distracted by arrival of night so well
caped woman enough time to bite his neck
and tear of his strode and then
repeatedly stabbing him in the face with
smell Jon's death the status of how
somber is uncertain while house
Karstarks castle lands and titles will
be most likely signed to start slow
lists same will happen to house embers
lands castle and titles if you're
wondering what if those two between
houses have young siblings and their
hairs well if they have hairs their
lands castles and titles are still going
to be divided to those who followed for
Jon Snow while to their young siblings
and their hairs again if there are ones
will happen the same what happened to
team Greyjoy after his father rebelled
and lost they will become hostages while
a lot of Game of Thrones fans are saying
that Jon doesn't have an army to support
any of his decisions I don't agree with
them
John has supportive houses which set out
of conflict which means that those
houses have full arm strength such as
the manderlys the sermons and the
Glovers which means that Jon has more
than enough man to support any of his
decisions in the north you might say
that John also has support of how serene
but you need to be careful about it yes
their Lord is Robin arena but Petyr
Baelish is the one in charge of how
serene Sinskey is manipulating with robb
in as we have seen few times it's a fact
that Petyr Baelish commenced Lord Romain
arene to use the Knights of Vale to help
his cousin Sansa Stark after escaping
the clutches of Ramsay Bolton while
robbing at first didn't want to
Littlefinger play a big role in Jon's
victory
actually if Petyr Baelish didn't decide
to help John Ramsay Bolton would have
been still alive it would have been in
charge of interval Valjean would have
been dead but don't think that
Littlefinger came to say John Petyr
Baelish came at night so well to set up
Sansa Stark as a rule of interval while
he failed to accomplish his main goal in
conclusion John we had to make some big
decisions about fate of two big noble
houses that betrayed how stark and
fought for house Bolton in my opinion
John will execute Harold Karstark for
his treason if he wins right battle
while castles lands and titles of house
Bolton house Karstark and house amber
will be divided to torment Davos spear
Baelish and other royal houses what's
your opinion on all of this what do you
think John is going to do with all the
castles lands and titles of all those
treacherous houses do you think that
Petyr Baelish is going to be satisfied
with getting one of castles and with a
few titles do you think the little
finger help John only to get that title
I don't think so
Petyr Baelish one is set up sense as a
role of in Val even maybe as a queen in
the north which she is by the rights at
least until bran survival there are also
questions like why the little finger in
helps Sansa to take the winner's foul
well from the very beginning it was old
Peters game Littlefinger puts ensign
Rams his hands in the first place only
because he knew that's going to give him
a chance to let's call it save her and
to help her retake Winterfell which
would give him support of the north once
he set up sense as the queen in the
north which she almost accomplished and
then if he would marry her
it will bring him the northern army this
part he has accomplished at least not
yet Brens arrivals rises a lot of
questions which I'm going to bring you
guys in my future videos also you can
expect in a few weeks from me to bring
your video about Petyr baelish's
aka will fingers faith in the upcoming
season hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you did please make sure to subscribe
to our channel and yeah see you the next
time peace
[Music]